and tell me when you're ready chivo
ready rotate into dialogue Kevo Emmanuel
lubeski the cinematographer was my first
privilege to ever get to work with him
and he's a great filmmaker and artist
and extremely specific about how the
walls should almost always be darker
than the faces of the actors and how the
camera moves and what it looks like and
it will enchant you and envelop you he's
such a part of the whole filmmaking
process so just gleeful when it goes
well and like a vision's been popping up
from behind the camera and she's going
keep it on you know ah my God you know
and he's almost crying with joy over
great shot you know he's a real artist
and this is chivo and no one has done
this as chivo has so it makes you want
to try harder it makes you want to make
something more beautiful and but he's
also fun to collaborate with
cartoons
okay I always thought this world was
beautiful the world is luscious and
precise it takes specific people to
create a living world just felt like I
was totally transported into a Time
David's regular upset designer made
beautiful sex she is an artist in her
own right Judy creates beautiful worlds
you want to go inside the world and you
want to learn about it she does it
Judy's way and it's her signature the
way she makes something beautiful we do
that one yeah we do a familiar one I
would do the green Green's the one all
right wardrobe is the person and you
always have to have a love affair with
the Wardrobe Jared Hall Baker creates an
incredible look that when people see the
movie they say to me I want Margo's
clothes I want her accessories and Jerry
Hall Baker created those clothes she
made everything beautiful every
character had their own look putting on
that coat in some of the uniforms felt
very empowering my character is very
dramatic and very artistic and very dark
I loved getting to explore that kind of
strong look trousers and capes and top
hats things like that it looks
spectacular and Jr she's such a rock
style she's so good the satisfaction of
seeing something from the absolute birth
of sitting with David with him going
I've got an idea and seeing him
gradually building that story ah it's
wonderfully satisfying it's beautiful
and specific and so luscious and
immediate that you're completely in and
it enchants you all right
[Music]